some new details now this morning after  three deadly car crashes around the  valley in as many hours four people lost  their lives two of them near the Fremont  Street Experience in that Collision  Metro Police say a 44 year old man and  51 year old woman were hit and killed in  a crosswalk this happened at about 7 30  last night Metro Police say the couple  was crossing against a don't cross  signal at the time 28 year old Michael  Terrell arrested for the crash  investigators believe she was under the  influence less than an hour earlier a  50-year-old man was hit and killed on  Boulder Highway near Russell Metro  Police say the victim was in a marked  crosswalk again when he was hit by an  SUV right now officers are trying to  find the driver of a silver or light  gray SUV they believe was involved now  these three deaths Mark 151 fatalities  in Metro's jurisdiction this year and  that equals the amount from last year